cet essai de travail sauve beaucoup de gens comme nous pouvons
parfois cela ne veut pas dire tout le monde
mais vous n'abandonnez pas le
cercle de New York Washington DC via d'
accord c'est assez capitaine les gens ont
peur
c'est pourquoi je suis ici
nous devons être mis en échec
quelle que soit la forme  ça prend je suis un jeu je suis
désolé Tony si je vois une situation dirigée vers le
sud je ne peux pas l'ignorer parfois
j'aimerais pouvoir parfois je veux te frapper dans
tes dents parfaites je sais que nous ne sommes pas
parfaits
mais les mains les plus sûres  Je suis toujours dehors
Je me suis trompé sur toi Le monde entier
s'est trompé sur toi Ils viennent pour
toi
Je ne suis pas celui qui doit surveiller
leurs arrières Cela ne doit pas se terminer par un
combat  bien ne vous inquiétez pas je pourrais faire
ça toute la journée d'
accord j'ai perdu patience
underoos hey tout le monde
vous